Narrator: Whether you need a snow storm,
a huge gust of wind,
or a fake rain shower,
this man's got you covered.
Some TV shows and movies film
scenes in extreme weather
to make the story feel more realistic.
But there's one big
problem with that approach.
Jeremy Chernick: You can
never count on the weather
to work for you.
Narrator: Jeremy Chernick is a designer
at J&M Special Effects in Brooklyn.
Chernick: You can't
schedule the entire crew
around waiting for snow.
Narrator: So you often
have to make it yourself.
Jeremy's company creates
practical special effects
for a variety of live shows, music videos,
and other productions.
Chernick: All the Disney Broadway shows,
"Aladdin," "Frozen."
Narrator: He made it rain on Shawn Mendes
at the 2018 MTV VMA's.
J&M also rents out equipment for TV shows
like "Gotham," and "Elementary."
Basically, any conditions you can imagine,
he can whip up.
But the trick to creating fake weather
is that it just needs to look
real in the camera frame.
Chernick: You don't need
all the weather in the world
to know it's raining in a shot this big.
You just need rain in the
background or rain on top.
Narrator: So what exactly does it take
to create the illusion of
weather on camera or on stage?
Chernick: There are a
lot of different ways
that rain is done.
And it depends on whether
you're interior or exterior.
Narrator: Outside, you
can get a permit to hook
up a hose to a fire
hydrant or a water truck.
Chernick: You can split
that water out to a variety
of locations, and usually high big towers
go up that can spray water
from unbelievably high.
Narrator: Indoors you
need a self-contained
system attached to water supply.
Chernick: Right above me is a rain bar.
So we have rain that
is pouring down in sort
of a five-inch channel, so
if you're looking dead at it,
it looks pretty three-dimensional
because you have
rain here and here, and
plus we can add a level
of sort of mist into that
that will just give it
an even larger depth of field.
And you can rows and
rows and rows of them.
The systems in place to keep
that rain from never ever
dripping unless you wanted
it to rain is actually
more complex than the moments
when it's actually raining.
It's mostly fairly low tech.
Narrator: There are a
number of different products
that are used to replicate snowflakes.
Chernick: You can get
pretty large paper flakes
that are squares and they
fall in a very beautiful
and specific way, you can
get shredded paper that falls
sort of organically.
You can get it shredded
plastic, which has a different
feel to it, and the way
that you deliver that
is through blowers that
are blowing it far overhead
and a long distance.
Narrator: They also have
special soap-based products
that won't stain clothes or
make the ground slippery.
Chernick: Essentially,
it's like tiny bits of foam
and that is a machine
that is pushing that soap
through a filter that
makes it into snowflakes.
Environmentally, there's
all sorts of stuff
that ends up in the air to fill a picture
in terms of haze, fog, smoke.
Narrator: These effects
are usually produced
with a fog machine.
Chernick: The most commonly
used interior fog is
glycol based, which is a type of alcohol.
Narrator: Sometimes you
want the fog to fill
the screen, and other times
you want low-lying fog,
which requires a few special tricks.
Chernick: That is most often
done now using liquid CO2,
or liquid nitrogen to chill the glycol fog
to a very cold level.
And that coldness is what
heats it low to the ground.
The thing that's funny about wind, to me,
is that you don't see
wind unless it's either
moving clothing or hair, or if it has
some fog or some level of fog in it.
Narrator: J&M has fans of all sizes.
We have incredibly quiet fans designed
specifically for live television.
Narrator: With any of
these weather effects,
you want to be extra careful to protect
camera equipment and the actors.
Chernick: There's a shield,
there's plastic bagging,
there's sometimes tents.
Narrator: There's also a
risk of flooding indoors.
Chernick: Often scenery is
going to be built and designed
with water catch underneath,
so it will be raining
on what looks like the floor,
but it's designed to collect water.
Narrator: While these weather systems
may not be exactly like the real thing,
they get the job done.
Chernick: You don't have to
do a huge amount of post work
if your special effects are
right and they look right.
And they're telling your story.
And the realistic stuff,
is you can tell it's real.